[Musica]
[Applauso]
ognuno di noi ha un proprio talento
berruto ne ha tantissimo io ne ho uno
solo sono cintura nera di trattoria cioè
io sono proprio un appassionato ci metto
il cuore allo stomaco tutto il mio corpo
il mio grande corpo ma non sono l'unico
è perché c'è una ricerca della
federazione italiana pubblici esercizi
uscita dieci giorni fa che dice che in
italia sono 34 milioni di italiani che
mangiano molto frequentemente fuori casa
e sono in aumento gli unici in europa
siamo gli unici in europa che vanno
sempre di più a mangiare fuori casa e
sono 5 milioni quelli che vanno a
mangiare fuori casa a pranzo tre quattro
volte la settimana quindi spessissimo
praticamente tutti i giorni lavorativi
fate conti ce li ho fatti io o perché mi
sono applicato 5 milioni di italiani per
250 giorni lavorativi la spesa e medietà
il 5 10 euro facciamo sette e mezzo
avete fatto il conto sicuramente ve lo
dico io fa quasi 10 miliardi cioè sono
quasi 10 miliardi di euro che tutti gli
anni spendiamo in pause pranzo un sacco
di soldi tutto il comparto vale quasi 90
miliardi è quindi tre finanziarie e
nostri alle nostre pause parate valgono
un terzo di una manovra di assestamento
ciononostante è intanto le mangiate ciò
nonostante ciò nonostante di tre torri e
ci occupiamo molto poco cioè sono molto
poco sui giornali molto poco sulle guide
come mai perché in generale ci occupiamo
più delle rappresentazioni che della
realtà no
guardiamo molto il calcio ma poi
facciamo poco sport sicuramente tra i
presenti siete sempre su youporn
ma fate pochissimo l'amore sapete tutto
della vita di carlo cracco di antonino
che lo so sai che sto parlando di te c'è
qualcuno che sa di chi sto parlando
e sappiamo tutto dalla vita in
cannavacciolo di caracas ha eccetera
però magari non sappiamo come si chiama
il signore che cucina nel bar dove
andiamo
tutti i giorni facciamo un esperimento
quanti di voi hanno mangiato in un
ristorante da più di 100 euro
nell'ultima settimana ma non è che non è
che ti mandiamo in italia nessuno 1 o
meno male equitalia e quanti di voi
hanno mangiato in una trattoria
nell'ultima settimana
io sicuramente bene questo dimostra che
allenatori e appunto sono molto popolari
non esattamente come voi vi dicevo vado
mangiare sempre datoriale lo faccio per
mestiere lo faccio per mestiere
recensisco tra tory e per repubblica
la differenza tra me e un cliente
normale e tiglio tutti i giorni cambio
tato via cioè le provo sempre di diverse
quindi in un anno le paolo 100 150 fino
adesso lavoro provato un 1000 1500
quindi la cintura nera mela merito
diciamo e in questi anni ho capito che
cosa che mi piace di una trattoria cioè
cosa che distingue una trattoria buona
dal mattatore normale
ora intanto la definizione trattoria per
la treccani una trattoria è tipo un
ristorante ma più semplice ora non
voglio far torta 3 cane però ci si
poteva spostare un po di più
allora io dico che secondo me una
trattoria e tipo ristorante ma più
semplice ma soprattutto un posto dove si
mangia a pranzo e dove vanno a mangiare
lavoratori studenti impiegati pensionati
cioè tutti quelli che hanno bisogno di
rispondere al più primordiale dei
bisogni che è la fame cioè chi va a
mangiare fuori parti accetti per scusate
per farne non per piacere
dunque cosa distingue la trattoria buona
da una trattoria normale secondo me due
elementi che non sono fisici cioè sono
fisici ma non sono cose non sono le
tovaglie a quadretti non sono e
lampadari in ferro battuto non è il
fiasco di chianti con la paglia quindi
quella data a trastevere non fatevi
prendere basterà per quello che conta in
una trattoria sono due ingredienti sono
due persone una il cuoco chiaro c'è una
persona che ci sappia fare col cibo
l'alta e lost è una persona che ci
sappia fare con le persone che perché la
trattoria la questione soprattutto di
accoglienza allora troppo spesso si fa
caso al cuoco ma si fa poco caso
all'hosting c quando entra tentatori ha
guardata
guardate prima di tutte le persone
possono non esserci le trattorie possono
le tovaglie possono essere di fiandra
voi guardate come lost e guardate come
fuoco e quindi fate una decisione fa
dentro la decisione però di rete
spendiamo 10 miliardi all'anno bla bla
bla l'italia è l'unico paese in crescita
perché dedicare questi otto minuti alle
trattorie perché tanto che sono in crisi
sono in difficoltà perché non molti
nemici un nemico e molto grosso e non
votate ma oggi è lì per normazione di
per tassazione il costo del lavoro
questi dibattiti qui tutte cose che
fanno sì che quello che un tempo e un
investimento quelli natatoria che si
ripaga va in tre anni
adesso necessita di dieci cioè uno che
prima la trattoria 20 anni fa ci mette a
tre anni per entrare quartiere adesso se
vi va bene se non muore prima come sto
facendo io adesso viene vogliono 10 ma
invece io mi voglio concentrare su due
nemici della trattoria due amici che in
realtà ci coinvolgono una e una certa
retorica la retorica del prodotto la
retorica della tradizione e la retorica
della territorialità del territorio sano
velocissimo sul territorio sono tutte
cose buone ma che si diventano retoriche
diventano cattive sul territorio
l'amministratore e preferite vi sono di
torino sono abruzzesi siciliane
calabresi perché sono stato detto che
inizia anche loro no ci sono qua da 30
anni 40 anni quindi non fatevi prendere
da sta roba e del local a tutti i costi
sui prodotti prodotti certo bisogna
avere prodotti buoni ma i prodotti
d'eccellenza riguardano solo il signore
che nato mangiare non possa 100 euro
noi invece dobbiamo occuparci di avere
prodotti di qualità nella qualità media
non è la qualità top e lo stesso una
tradizione c'è una famosa frase di
michael pollan del giornalista michael
pollan che dice non mangiare niente che
tua bisnonna non riconoscerebbe come
cibo ora una figlia
no michael pollan ha sicuramente ragione
ma andando indietro di business bisnonna
dovremmo mangiare con le bacchette c'è
nesso che invece è tutta la tradizione
stata contemporanea quindi non stiamo
troppo l'altro nemico delle trattorie
siamo un po noi non voi mano i critici
che le consideriamo un poco sui giornali
sulle riviste sulle guide allora le
trattorie hanno un amico solo in questo
amico siamo noi noi tutti che spendiamo
i nostri 10 miliardi all'anno ma non
siamo abbastanza forti
abbiamo bisogno di un alleato e sto per
dirvi un alleato che particolarmente
scomodo cioè e diciamo è il verdini
degli alleati delle trattorie questo
alleato si può dire per dire che tanto
scomodo per tutti è che uno sia questo
alleato si chiama tripadvisor io so che
molti di voi odiano tripadvisor perché
pieno di commenti falsi di marchette
eccetera eccetera ma invece uno
strumento potente e visto che esiste non
possiamo far finta che non esista vi
racconto solo questo piccolo aneddoto
qualche tempo fa in una cartolina vicino
a me c'era la signora le dico se mangia
bene qua e là di ciò si mangia benissimo
la fattore migliore della vita e dico
brava signora sono felice che lei si
accontenti tutte le volte che torno a
casa
faccio un commento su tripadvisor.it
obama se ne va così finalmente dice no
ma io vado a casa era su un pallino
felice perché lascia un pallino si
lascia un pallino così la gente non
viene qua a rompere le palle
e le dico sì viola
[Applauso]
l'applauso e per la signora presi e lo
porterò allora noi dobbiamo cambiare
verso come si dice la leopolda a questo
trip advisor dobbiamo fare la nostra
parte quando andate a mangiare una
trattoria e mangiate bene tornate a casa
ha portato una carezza alla tra boss
tanta teoria da parte ne ha
mettete 5 pallini e questa è la mia call
to action e quindi vi chiedo davvero
usate tripadvisor in un lavoro perché
miser usatelo bene usatelo bene il mio
motto finale è la forza scorre il
potente in trip advisor
ma è il lato oscuro della forza
riportiamo tripadvisor sul lato chiaro
dalla forza